j'ai arrêté la cigarette ya six mois
voilà c'est moi et j'ai tenu deux mois
deux mois j'étais bien non mais c'est
marrant que tu arrêtes la clope parce
qu'il ya plein de gens qui viennent te
voir antennes opta qui tu vas voir en
arrêtant la cigarette au bout de
quelques temps tu vas retrouver le goût
des aliments est un peu franchement
serait au bout de quelques temps lors
des trois semaines j'avais retrouvé mon
goût on va dire un peu plus intense des
aliments et c'est précisément à ce
moment là je me suis rendu compte à quel
point la cuisine de ma femme mais elle
est éclatée contre un mur j'avais je
préférais quand le cabba inique et les
papilles gustatives que huawei et moi
les gens qui détestent le plus haut en
couleurs c'est le 9 mai pour moi et à
vous et nous voilà je vous déteste époux
malatray vous rendez pas compte comme
c'est dur pour nous si vous venez nous
voir avec vos conseils de mer de leurs
frères avant dégoûté la preuve cette
lettre à kim la clope c'est rien tu
pourrais t'en passer un arrête arrête de
faire comme c'était
attendu que les caps la page est pas moi
à la place mange une pomme ça passe
mon jeune fils de [ __ ]
tu sais que j'essaie d'écouter je tourne
à 13 fois par jour je devais voulons un
pommier j'étais devenu évident je chie
est incomplète et normal ça me ronge
leurs votes
et plus excuser moi excusez moi mais la
pomme c'est quoi cet objet de lien
social éclaté la pomme quoi la cigarette
ça crée du lien je demande du feu à
quelqu'un tu discutes ça va à l'iran ça
se passe comment ces carrés mais la
pomme c'est quoi la pomme n'a pas une
excuse moi ce que j'aurais une pomme à
dépanner monsieur secours une vingtaine
safra la faire passer beaucoup plus
n'importe quoi et ces gens aussi qui te
disent oui à kim c'est dommage avec tout
ce que tu fumes si tu mettais à côté
dans dix ans tu pourrais acheter une
ferrari mes frères ça fait dix ans que
je te connais tu fume pas tu rentres
migaud
bon